all right let's get into the night shot
is this gonna be the thumbnail
that's crazy man hey guys this is vadim
with maxtec and this is my brother
max and my sister angelica and in this
video we are doing a camera comparison
between the
iphone 12 pro the note 20 ultra and
google pixel 5.
and this isn't like any other camera
comparison this is completely blind
because
over the weekend i went and took a bunch
of photos with all three of these phones
and i put them all together in this
timeline and they haven't ever seen
these phones so it's completely
unbiased completely blind and i have to
say that i'm super excited to be a part
of this usually i'm the one hosting it
and they're the ones choosing
so i can't wait to see what my results
are and both of us
we have papers and pens here we're gonna
be seeing which photo we like the best
and then marking it down and choosing a
winner so we have two of us this time
and we want you to play along so go
ahead and get another get a piece of
paper and a pen and write down your
results in the comments
and this first shot is aiming directly
at the sun as you guys can see we had a
snow storm on friday so
what do you guys think what's the best
i'm definitely not voting for the one on
the left
snow is not blue and these two are kind
of tough but i'm choosing the right one
because i think the white balance is
spot-on we get a little bit more details
in the sky
i'm also picking the one on the right
but i think the one on the left is
actually not that bad
okay that's the iphone 12 pro so there's
your smart hdr3
doing work all right in our next one
this is like a very close up of a chain
with ice it looks awesome and it's
portrait right
no it's not it's not portrait this is
just close up yep natural blur
uh for me this is easy definitely the
one in the center it stands out
so much among the rest i also voted for
the one in the center
but it wasn't an easy one for me all
right it's the note 20 ultra
there you go this is my son eugene i
don't know if you guys remember from the
ipad pro versus
20 20 ipad pro comparison
go ahead i'm voting for the one on the
left not only because of expression
which is awesome
um i like just how your face looks more
natural
this is shockingly dark and crushed yeah
my shirt is completely black
and like kind of blotchy on my face this
is these two are pretty close but
definitely left
iphone 12 pro okay there you go he likes
to stand up in front of a mirror
this one it's hard because obviously you
want the one where your kid is facing
you but i'm still voting for center not
for that reason
because there's a lot more detail here
in the carpet
in his onesie not that it matters in
this photo you want the expression but
i kind of like the one on the left all
right left is note 20
center is iphone 12. so far none for the
pixel 5. sorry you guys um
well we'll see yeah there you go this
one's kind of tough because they're all
so similar i gotta say this one is very
tough
um it's a toss-up between these two for
me um it looks like there's a little bit
extra noise the texture is not as
i don't know it's this is such a hard
thing okay so she's going left
you're going center yeah so note 20
center pixel five that's so interesting
that the iphone usually wasn't as
colorful in the past samsung would
usually do that but this looks better to
me there you go selfie against the sun
this is a very tough
situation right here i know which one
i'm voting for
center even though the face isn't as
bright i hate all the flaring here yeah
that flare
that's a this one it looks
the colors like what color what color
shirt were you wearing uh it's basically
navy blue okay because that is not
that does not look right and your face
looks kind of blotchy i don't like any
of them but yeah the the center one
center
pixel five look at that not bad iphone
yeah this is bad i don't know what
happened here like my face is all just
flat there you go that's my wife she
went out and took her own photos
i prefer the one on the left just
because of the detail on the fur just
looks nicer than the center one
for me i think the center one has a lot
more detail
true detail that looks a little bit over
sharpened iphone 12 pro in the center
note 20 on the left that must be deep
fusion then
yeah i mean camera if you look at the
detail like you're seeing all the fibers
like look at her shirt
you're seeing all those little fibers
and everything
so yeah we have deep fusion on all the
cameras on the new iphone 12 pro which
is really really nice
and it's definitely working here there
you go eugene
he's teething i have to say that all
these cameras
it's hard to do a great job at least
into what we've seen so far
yeah i would be happy with any of these
but i think the one in the center
center even though the white balance
isn't perfect i can warm it up a little
if i want to
uh this is really really tough but i'm
going to pick the one on the left i
don't mind the flaring
so pixel 5 in the center iphone 12 pro
on the left so this is a sunset
shot of the snow using the ultra wide
lens on all of them oh this is pretty
tough but i think i like the one in the
center
the most i definitely know which one i
don't like which is the one on the left
it looks too flat
this pops a little too much but i like
it for this shot with the sunset
center iphone 12 pro right note 20 ultra
alright so this
is a zoom photo and they're all kind of
matched up
yeah can you say the one on the left
okay yep
this looks like a dslr type shot with
like a kit lens
this looks like it's over sharpened and
this just looks noisy
and flat no tony ultra of course it has
the 5x optical
geez which the others don't got some
organic eggs right here
left left okay that was that was quick
really quick
center left iphone 12 pro center note 20
ultra
and this just looks almost like it could
be a dslr shot with a define ultra fine
details
deep fusion all right here's a portrait
shot with each of them
in the center for me pixel 5. look at
that
yeah let me see closer that looks good
did a good
job yeah that looks really my hair isn't
crushed either go you got a portrait
shot of a pine cone right one right one
yeah
yeah right one right one looks like a
dslr it looks good huh
look at her ring it looks great it's
sharp yeah
the cutout's really good too look at
this that is we cut this out perfectly
it did
where this is kind of this got rid of it
this is kind of smeared a little bit
look at her look at the finger yeah the
ring is gone yeah
the rings kind of blurt slightly the
nails are kind of messed up look at
google's algorithm
google what are you doing all right so
here's a selfie portrait with all three
of them i had to crop in a little bit to
fit them all
right right okay right oh yeah right
right okay
iphone 12 pro so what's interesting is
you're the white balance on your face
yeah is perfect your skin tone actually
looks like real life
and look at the detail here there you go
this is a
wide portrait so using the wide lens uh
i think i definitely like the one in the
center the most
and like if you look at her shoes like
they're perfectly in focus compared to
the left one where it starts to get
blurry
i know which one i don't want is this
one definitely these are so close this
one's by far off and look at the
purple leggings compared to these two
they were black okay you're going left
you're going center right
see one thing with the left here is that
it's crushed see the hair
that's one downside i saw there but no
twenty
pixel five in the center note 20 on the
left what did the iphone do
here is another portrait shot once again
look at the leggings
i'm definitely not choosing that one
it's tough i'm going left again left i'm
going right
you're going right okay left and right
okay pixel 5 on the left note 20
on the right lika you and i flipped all
right
let's get into the night shot is this
going to be the thumbnail
that's crazy man it looks like clickbait
all right well i think we know which one
we're voting for unless they're trying
to be artistic
as making a ghost looking thing over
here
wow one on the left it's obviously the
note 20 ultra because it has
50x zoom and when you can zoom in that
much
it can actually get the exposure correct
that's 50x
50x these ones i had to impose cropping
more
usually when you're taking a photo with
the wide lens the
moon is so tiny and so you need a really
long tele
this is this is what that's what zoom
does there you go this is
downtown spokane at the pavilion this is
actually a
using the wide lens and all of them a
nighttime portrait shot so that's one of
the
latest things that the iphone has added
this year using
lidar so for me it definitely is not the
one on the right
the colors look off there's a lot of
detail loss and artifacting and noise
here
where here we have nice detail
everywhere even though the white balance
maybe i'd want it warmer
i'd choose detail i agree so iphone 12
pro it
does an excellent job like the focus
with the lidar is spot on
what do you guys think this is just
using the wide lens and i cropped in a
little bit to get closer on
this building i like this one because
this looks horrible to me but i just
like the extra detail here this one
looks like this might be out of focus or
something
i'm going to go with the one in the
center so center pixel five
left note 20 alternatives this is a
night mode
shot with the wide lens uh
right right okay i like the one in the
center
okay i'm changing to left you're
changing to left so your center your
left okay
center is iphone 12 pro left is pixel 5.
right this is
another nighttime portrait shot this is
pretty hard but i think i like the one
on the left the most
i agree i'm going to left just because
it looks the cleanest
um this has a little bit of blotchiness
in here this one has the most
blotchiness and kind of
i don't know over sharpening something
there's a lot of crushing
on those iphone 12 pro on the left does
a pretty good job with those
and here's another zoom shot i cropped
in to match them up
i would want this one so right yep
youtube that's the note this is the
ultra wide this is an ultra wide night
mode shot which the iphone also has now
just like the others left left look at
the dynamic range there
yeah look at this is so blown out there
and kind of overexposed not as
i don't know that's the one for me i
agree left okay
note 20 ultra this is a nighttime selfie
shot
it deems such a cheesy smile
whatever it's okay i was just trying to
it was cold
it was freezing i'm going for the center
one freezing cold center okay the center
one is nice but i i think i kind of want
to go for the left
pixel five ah google with their
algorithm
and this is the ultra wide of the
pavilion obviously
the colors did change as i was taking
these so don't judge off that so
maybe just look at i don't know details
i like this one man
i love the contrast i love how you
really see all these little lines and
how everything just
pops me too iphone 12 pro geez that
looks
yeah it's very detailed if you look up
close it looks like deep fusion is
working
and that is actually it that's our last
one here's the last one as a bonus
there we go we obviously have the phones
here this is a mirror shot
but there you go we have all the phones
so that was 25
photos what do you guys have what are
your results and you guys as well
what did you guys make sure pause count
we want to hear
honest unbiased opinions i gotta say
this is really fun so we have our
results
make sure you commented i gotta say i'm
very unbiased
i have nine for the iphone 12 pro nine
for the note 20 and seven
for the pixel five i gotta say i'm very
unbiased i got the same thing
really nine for the iphone 9 for the
notes
i think that means that all of these are
fantastic
phones good cameras you're not gonna get
too bad of shots i guess in certain
cases
phone certain phones do better it's
really close i mean we gotta hand it to
the pixel because it's seven hundred
dollars instead of
a thousand plus so yeah or thirteen
hundred dollars it didn't do as well
and the pixel doesn't have that
telephoto lens yeah
so in certain in certain cases the pixel
does fall short because of a couple
things but in other cases with the main
camera and i say i think 50 to 70 of my
photos are just with the standard lens
yeah without zooming in it does a great
job good job
google i want to let you know that we
are going to do another blind camera
comparison but including the s20 fe
against the standard iphone 12 and the
pixel 5 because those are so similar in
price points i want to know how samsung
does at that price point
not at thirteen hundred dollars so make
sure you guys have notifications enabled
for that
and also click that circle above to
subscribe because we are doing an
ultimate comparison we're gonna be
taking the iphone
10s the iphone 11 pro and the 12 pro
and basically looking at all of the
differences and improvements
through those three generations just to
show you guys if it's worth upgrading if
you have one of those phones
alright guys we'll see you in the next
video